young left-hander justice sheffield who
was a first-round pick back in 2014 by
cleveland he has come to the mariners by
way of the yankees he does not have a
win
and is very stingy in terms of giving up
home runs here is mookie bets to leave
things off swing and a miss for strike
three and justice sheffield strikes out
the very first banner of the ball game
mookie bets
holy smokes and there's one away for the
dodgers here in the first inning here is
shortstop corey seeger younger brother
of kyle so once again brother against
brother broken back ground ball to the
shortstop bumping the ball jp crawford
on the other side of the bag scoops
throws the first in time to get corey
seeger
and right away two outs for the dodgers
here is designated hitter justin turner
that's four pitch walk for turner the
dodgers have their first base runner
there is catcher will smith here's a
swing and a fly ball into right field
and right there is mitch hanigar to make
the catch and that will retire the side
a nice start for sheffield flame
throwing dustin may looks for his second
win
may had 14 strikeouts on the season in
just over 10 innings pitched looking for
some more punch outs but he wants to go
a little deeper into the game than he
did last time mitch hannah are going to
lead things off he chases a breaking
ball for the first out tonight that'll
bring up third baseman ty france
fastball swinging a ground ball base hit
into left field
catches up to a 99 mile an hour fastball
france is aboard with the game's first
hit a one-ounce single kyle seeger is
the designated hitter tonight the older
brother of corey seeger
[Music]
[Applause]
he did
[Applause]
[Music]
that'll bring up left fielder jose
marmaleos marmalayosa swinging a drive
deep to right field this one is gonna be
gone goodbye baseball line drive home
run into the lower deck
how in the world you got any laundry
mariners have a two nothing lead over
the dodgers doubling their first inning
run total for the year with that one
swing here's center fielder taylor
tremell here's a swing and a drive deep
into the gap in left center field and
this one is going and going and goodbye
baseball
taylor tremell
with an opposite field home run out to
the pin and the mariners now lead the
dodgers by a score of three to nothing
offensive numbers not very good since
mookie came back from missing a few days
with the back 4 22 in that time that
slashes it to right center tremella the
move don't get there extra bases for
bets a two-out double here in the third
nobody ever mentions the reverse jinx
when you talk about a guy who's
struggling and then he gets a double he
gives corey seeger a two-out chance in a
three-nothing game here in the third how
about the sega brothers it's always a
great story when these two clubs get
together for inter league play and in a
game last year they both hit a home run
sneaker grounded out his first time
below 180 over his last 10.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he jumps on the first pitch and hammers
a two-run shot and it's 3-2
with a little two-out burst
justin turner d.h tonight
turner reps it on the ground down the
line the third consecutive hit with two
out the third consecutive extra base hit
as turner settles into second with a
double if will smith is able to bring
home turner to tie the game here it'll
be his first rbi in two weeks
the o2
strike three caught him up lower inside
corner at 94.
lead off walk to taylor and now the
dodgers have to tie and run aboard
that'll bring up left fielder aj pollock
swung on a little pop-up behind first
base down the right field line white
going back dives and he makes the kids
oh my goodness
what a play by evan white he didn't give
up on it and he makes a basket catch
over his shoulder what a play by evan
white one out for the dodgers here in
the top of the fourth and that kid can
do it all with a glove chris taylor had
a beat on the baseball and just did not
make the play the mariners have a man
aboard with two outs sending skepta live
for tramell corenz goes three two pits
one on line drive base it down the right
field line and toward the corner sliding
and safe at home is luis terrence
and the mariners now lead the dodgers
four to two
so the taylor air turns into another run
ty france came out and took a couple
ground balls made a couple throws and
said that's not happening after getting
hit by that 98 mile per hour fastball
right in the forearm so the mariners
will get a new third baseman hopefully
it is named thing series two on two out
in a two run game they're gonna leave
sheffield on at least one more hitter
here with the left-handed betting
mckinstry climbing in mckinstry has been
a lefty killer it's a liner to center
in front of base hill turner's headed
home it's 4-3 zach mckenstry comes
through yet again and that's going to do
it for sheffield he's not going to
survive the sixth this is will vest
the rookies giving up just one earned
run over his first seven games comes in
a 4-3 game with two on and two out
luke raley comes off the bench a
left-handed hitter swinging gonna miss
struck him out ending over
best is pumped as he comes off the mound
[Applause]
who's one of three pitchers for the
mariners already with multiple saves
this year turner coming to the play with
two on and one out dodgers down by a run
here in the seventh swing it'll be
struck him out oh baby what a big one
sinking fastball gets justin turner two
down here in the seventh seeger and bets
aboard mariner bullpen has been nails
and they're trying to keep that run
going it's up to will smith swung on and
hit oh what a catch a diving leaping
catch by dylan moore getting over an
inning saving and perhaps lead saving
catch so to the ninth inning we go on
rafael monteiro who has two saves but
has also blown three saves over his
first eight games tying one reaches as
rio straws the wall and now bets who is
two for four tonight one two again
very similar to an area that ty france
was hit on the underside of the right
forearm area mookie's still in the game
and so are the dodgers
4-3 9th inning corey seeger comes up
swinging a ground ball to the second
baseman agardy over to second for one
the relay to first the ball game is over
holy smokes the double play ends it and
the mariners hang on and they beat the
dodgers here at t-mobile park a final
score of four to three to take the
opening game of this brief two-game
series